hello everyone and welcome to another
truly spectacular game from the aim
chess preliminaries we are in day three
and it is gookish versus Magnus Carlsen
as you can see with their two ratings
The bookish is rated some 300 rating
points lower than Magnus Carlsen uh
which is uh quite a lot but uh if you
know their classical ratings you know
that gookish is some 2730 in Magnus is
28 like 50 2860 so it's not uh as great
but that the difference in classical is
even greater than this one appears here
the the the the the difference in
classical I mean it is just incredible
that Magnus is so much higher rated
which makes this incredible Victory even
that more satisfying so not just by
beating Magnus Carlsen but also by
becoming the youngest player ever to
defeat Magnus Carlsen since Magnus
became world champion uh prior to this
the record was held by pregnant and
another Indian Grandmaster who defeated
Magnus Carlsen on February 20th at the
age of 16 years six months in 10 days
and Google cashier is a 16 years 4
months and 20 days old now all that's
left is for us to enjoy the game so
let's dive straight into it and it's
quite a theoretical struggle first 18
moves are pure Theory uh so prepare for
that as well gookish has the white
pieces and he opens with Ponte E4 we
have Ponte E6 Magnus goes for the French
defense Ponta D4 we have Pawn to D5 and
Knight to C3 so the very standard stuff
Knight to F6 this is the classical
variation E5 Knight F the D7 and now
Ponta F4 the shine its variation we have
Pawn to C5 and now Knight to F3 so
fighting for the D4 Square we have
Knights the C6 Bishop to E3 and now Pawn
to A6
uh we have Queen to D2 by gookish uh
Pawn to B5 and now D captures and C5 we
have Bishop characters Bishop captures
Knight captures and now Bishop to D3 uh
it's okay to give up the bishop here as
it's all standard Theory we have Queen
to B6 by Magnus and now Queen to F2 not
allowing the knights to move as the
queen would hang and even if you play
Knight captures on D3 which check it's
not a problem C captures on D3 and now
if Queen captures King captures uh White
is very very happy with this end game so
instead Magnus goes for B4 as one always
should Knight the E2 and now we have
Pawn to A5 just um further expanding on
the queen side adding more support to
the B5 pawn and at some point preparing
Bishop to A6 so here gookish Castle's
Magnus goes for the dash of the A6 move
right away and now Pawn to F5 again
nothing new here all been played before
E captures on F5 and now as you freed up
the F4 Square for your Knight Knight the
F4 for preparing this very nasty Ponte
E6 and Magnus welcomes it as also the D5
Pawn is hanging so Knight to E7 guarding
the D5 pawn and now Pawn to E6 and you
don't really want to react to this
because for example F captures on E6
runs into Knight captures on E6 and this
is uh very annoying now because if Queen
captures then Queen captures on C5 and
also if Knight captures you've just
blundered your queen on B6 that's
another reason why Queen to F2 is such a
nice move so instead Magnus plays F6
this is how you should play this again
this is all Theory and you know the
general understanding is that black
should be a little bit better here and
now usually in the games that have
reached this position Rook to a rook a
to D1 and Rook F to D1 are the moves uh
Rook F31 and Rook a31 but here bookish
plays Rook a to C1 and it is now as of
move 18 that we have a completely new
game
and okay Magnus Castle's King side uh of
course you can't have your king in the
center of the board for the rest of the
game Pawn the C3 now as The Rook is now
supporting the pawn uh Queen to D6
putting pressure on the Knight on F4 we
have Bishop captures and A6 by Lucas
Rook captures and now C captures and uh
sorry C characters on B4 uh and now
Knight to E4 uh putting pressure on the
queen on F2 so Queen to E3 and now a
captures on B4 we have Knight to D4 by
gukash uh and now Magnus grabs the pawn
on A2 with Rook captures on A2 and this
is perfectly fine if you count material
Magnus is up to pawn so he's very happy
with that and gukesh has some very
unpleasant pressure he has the knights
in the center of the board the pawn on
E6 is quite beautiful and if he can uh
make use of the queen and the Rooks uh
that attack the black king somehow
should be perfectly fine we have Knight
the B5 now attacking the queen and the
Magnus goes Queen to E5 now with some
ideas of Queen captures on B2 in the
future then you can put pressure on the
G2 Pawn so white has to be very careful
Lucas plays Rook to C7 and this is such
a complicated position that it's hard to
really make out what's what here uh the
the objective evaluation of the position
is that Magnus is just winning but it's
hard for you to even pick a move here
none of the moves here you see are uh uh
are are all that great for example you
might uh you might think okay let's play
D4 we attack the queen and the Knight
but you can just play Queen capture
Sundee for and if Queen captures on B5
now there's Rook captures on E7 and I
mean it's it it's not much the only way
to actually play this after Rook to C7
is for Magnus to find the Knight the G6
and the point is now after Knight to D3
attacking the queen now you do have D4
and now after Knight captures an E5 D
captures on E3 let's say Knight captures
on g6h cam chapters and E7 or something
you can block and the black is now just
winning here the past E Pawn is here you
can capture on B2 you have the pass B
Pawn so uh all in all it would be
winning but uh this is rapid chess and
Knight the G6 is not a move that just
comes to mind so here Magnus played Rook
the E8 and he allowed gookish such a
brilliant move that uh well once you see
it and of course I will allow you to
pause the video and find it you will in
the do pause the video and find it you
will feel very happy with yourself once
you find this one you will want to share
it with everyone immediately
as it's just not something you would see
every day so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this move that
defeated Magnus calls and end allowed
gookish to become youngest player ever
to defeat Magnus Carlsen since he became
a world champion uh have at it
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that the
queen on E5 is actually trapped and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Queen to B6 look at this I'm
gonna do it in slow motion from uh the
first time it's such a good move so
congratulations to everyone who founded
this and now the idea behind Queen to B6
for those of you who haven't seen this
game although I imagine uh most of you
have is to defend the E6 pawn and now
the threat of Knight to D3 is just too
great The Queen will get attacked and
also the Knight will be defending the B2
Pawn so the black queen will not have
any squares but it's such a it's such a
rich position surely there must be
something Magnus can do here uh nope
there isn't point is that if you try
nice the G6 now which is a valid idea I
mean now okay the rook and the queen are
attacking E6 so if the Knight attacks
the queen you can just capture the E6
Pawn well now just Queen B7 that's the
the other idea behind the queen to B6
there's no stopping Rook captures on G7
and you're just getting destroyed here
so Knights the G6 collapses instantly so
what else is there for Magnus can he try
something like Queen captures on B2
maybe he can save the queen this way
Well turns out nope but just Rook
captures on E7 that's what the gookish
found uh and now there there's no you're
just down material and there's no good
way to continue this game the Knight is
guarding the G2 Pawn so there's no
uh actually uh capturing on G2 if you
capture The Rook here then just Queen to
d8 check Rook 8 and queen characters is
Checkmate and if you try something like
um after this Rook captures uh an E7
maybe you play well there's really not
all that much you can play it's uh I
mean real characters I mean it will be
made in one the pawn is uh covering the
F7 Square so that that obviously doesn't
work so what else is there you could try
Rook back to A8 this is also one fine
attempt but this just allows the main
idea which is nice the D3 trapping the
queen and now look at this because of
the sorry because of the Pawn on E6 uh
let's say Rook 8 to B8 it goes after the
queen and B6 and now you just play Queen
captures on B8 Rook captures on V8
Knight captures on E5 F captures an E5
and now Rook capture Sun E7 that's the
beauty of it and uh Magnus will be very
happy if he could capture on B5 and try
and play out this end game being down
the exchange the problem is if you do
this Rook that E8 is once again
Checkmate as
there's just no no playing this uh
uh I mean you're getting checkmated so
after this queen to B6 move it would
seem that the best move for Magnus is
just to resign the game and he was I
believe he was considering it I was
watching his uh facial expressions when
he was calculating this and he was he
was so disgusted with himself it was it
was beautiful to watch uh I mean such
pain is very rarely seen in uh in in a
live stream uh but uh yeah okay he
didn't resign he played Knight to G5
here he tried uh the the the defend with
some tactics okay the Knight now covers
H7 so maybe you don't get checkmated
gookish immediately played Rook
characters on E7 as this is the way to
go again Rook captures runs into Queen
to d8 with the check and the Checkmate
will follow but now after this capture
Magnus retreated The Rook to A8 so Rook
e to A8 and now we have Queen the C7
says I don't really care uh I'm a
material I'm offering a queen trade also
I'm threatening Rook captures on G7 so
between the E3 Check nagukas Place King
to H1 and it was in this position on
move 29 that Magnus Carlsen resigned the
game and gookers became the youngest
player ever to defeat Magnus Carlsen
since becoming world champion uh it
seems like maybe you have something here
but uh no you really don't for example
if Queen F2 hoping for Rook captures an
A1 Checkmate Rook day one Checkmate
there's the very nasty Rook captures on
G7 even this I mean everything works
here for Lucas that Quinta B6 simply
opened up Pandora's Box for King h8 and
now even Rook captures on H7 doesn't
even matter that Magnus played this
Knight to G5 because after Knight
captures Knight the G6 check only move
King to G8 and now Queen to F7 is
Checkmate again complements of the E6
Pawn so once uh once we go back to this
position and you have this like uh let's
say this position and the pawn is an E6
and objectively black is much better but
you can see how many how much trouble
blacks in and how many problems black
has to solve due to this Pawn being on
E6 and especially after this Rook d8
move was played I mean the spectacular
Queen to B6 we can check it out once
again just Queen to B6 uh pre I mean
such a beautiful move
uh so yeah that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it the glucose really did a
number and Magnus in this one I mean
truly truly outstanding 29 moves to take
down uh the the world champion
absolutely brilliant stuff by gookish so
yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it we'll see who will overtake
gookish as the youngest player to ever
beat uh Magnus uh or will some other
records be there to to be broken we'll
see what the future holds uh so yeah
once again hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to thank Duncan wine called
women life Freedom Lord of Chess
Anderson Vera and Antonio Hernandez
Espin for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day